the more pain you've been through the
stronger your message is gonna be
everybody that I've seen crush it came
from a really bad situation I used to
think like killing myself is the only
way to get relief but now I know that I
was completely wrong I've never had
suicidal thoughts so I can't really help
somebody who's suicidal but you can and
if you help somebody walk they're about
to jump off a bridge by talking to you
or they'll watch your video and they'll
take a step back and reevaluate
fill you up for life I grew up with like
I had a concussion my my cousin hit me
in the head with a baseball bat
okay okay uh-huh so I don't know that
was when our two years old so don't know
okay that damage they did that mean I
grew up pretty with learning pretty good
he was 15 I was locked in a locker room
people still someone forced me to fight
him and got a kitchen that way I don't
know he's long story I don't know a
second concussion it's a concussion then
I hit my head on a hay fork the next day
the next day the next day Wow okay I had
a second impact and had three
concussions and developed post
concussion syndrome had a lot of
problems doctors didn't know how to help
me thanks al and then at 19 years old I
was living with it the second I was 15 I
was living with all the problems that
comes with that and then randomly
assaulted on the street by by a man hit
my head on the ground twice is so that I
panicked because I didn't fully lose
consciousness but I felt two large bumps
on the back yeah and those are he more
like you know so subdural hematomas or
something on top and I panicked so I
heard something about nootropic so I got
into that I got into like different
nutrition mortalities and start feeling
like I was getting better and like just
a few just about a year ago I tried what
I thought was CBD all and it within two
hours of taking it I started
hallucinating like crazy I felt like
there's a demon inside me because it
blasted it was long lasting
schizophrenia pretty much as what it
rewired my brain so then long story
short I did so many different things and
trying to get myself back I did
electroconvulsive there be shocking my
brain trying to reset it it's been a
long story but so that's a lot of
suffering that I've been break I started
looking at it differently because I okay
every where in my brain I started doing
our feedback which is like where you
conditioning yourself to have different
brain waves are things so I started
doing that and I just started delving
into personal growth more about like
mindset and what just like you said at
the last just yesterday talking about
mindset I completely agree with that
100% and that got me back so it was
meditation and a lot of just a lot of
brain training that I did so now I want
to like start a YouTube channel with
like similar to like a SEP science and
like after school different know if you
know those or not it's like I know in
snap drawings yeah it's pretty soon
enemies just animations and just
explaining different ways to train your
brain but in a fun educational way so
for kids it could be for kids I'd like
to do it for everyone that feels like
they need to help their brain function
better but
okay that's kind of my dream my dream is
also public speak and help people with
mental illness or just any type of brain
performance video I haven't started yeah
I know you said take actions up I am I'm
a perfectionist to side I was afraid to
post it I recorded it I've been trying
to record it okay I've been recording it
and then just erasing the recording
because I'm not pleased with it okay
just the audio um both visual and audio
and also I don't know how to like get it
right the lighting like this so it's
just starting right like if it's if it's
the YouTube channel that you want to get
great at and spread your message then
how long even think about the YouTube
channel um actually been thinking about
it for a year actually I just it kind of
turned into just when I was trying to
figure out how I get my message out
there and just give to people and
contribute and to me my suffering like
help others because I that that stuck
with me and said pain is the purpose
that's something that I mean plenty of
times I wanted in my life try to and
stuff but I can't kept trying so I I
guess I just want to want to help a lot
of people with with any type of brain
health so yeah I just don't know exactly
how to get that message out there if
it's marketing or what exactly to like
get more people to notice me I guess
well you can put anything out there
market there's nothing to market yeah I
to get it up and it's the same approach
listen I think you know the the more
pain that you've been through the
stronger your message is gonna be I had
a guy DM me on Instagram and asked if I
haven't been through any pain or
suffering can I still have a strong
message and like you know what I don't
know like everybody that I've seen crush
it came from a really bad situation
and so that's a great starting point but
it's taking the same approach that when
you were trying to figure out how to
heal your mind
you tried like a million different
things right and eventually found the
thing of meditation and mindset that
work to you but you had things that
didn't work and things that set you back
and so the same thing for for your
YouTube channel you just start and it
may not work in the first video might
suck right and it will great but it's
been a year imagine what you could have
done in that year it's a good point
right if you make a video a week for a
year you could have had 52 videos and
you'd figure out the lighting then you'd
figure out your pitch of your voice and
how long the you know whatever whatever
you're concerned about being good enough
I love what you said the other day -
there's so many points that you had that
was spot-on
and it was like following your goals
following through with them because
that's something that I get into
something so much and then I just quit
but this is this I've stuck with because
it's been so much pain and suffering
behind it that I've had this tattoo no
choice had no choice it was desperation
out of everything but you know simple
things like juggling or something I'm
like Oh that'd be fun to learn oh yeah
learned it like hunted something else
but this is I just kept coming back to
me it's like into my face and I can't
ignore it
and it's the only thing that brings me
joy yeah one you'll what will bring you
even more joy is now helping somebody
else who had similar background to you
who doesn't know how to figure it out
they've had concussions and they feel
lost and they don't know what to do and
their parents don't know what to do when
their families don't know what to do but
then that girl finds her videos and
suddenly the app oh right that will fill
you up yeah like you believe you're a
thought leader so I need you to teach me
how you think I'm not coming because of
really good draw with fashion or the
drawing or leave you know six-pack ABS
there or whatever isn't right I'm coming
to learn the knowledge you have so
that's the most important part is are
you sharing great knowledge that can
help me so what's the first video got
about theirs see like my mom rents a job
that's and I can't just focus on one
thing that's just doing it but one of
them was a visualization of that's
that's helped me and I I visioned myself
as a conductor when I get into an alpha
theta state and I just act like I'm
conducting I move my hands as weird as
it sounds they can aesthetically move
and I feel like activates different
centers of my motor cortex they can and
you do that one you do the conductor
when you need to what kind of sync my
brain to a brain wave that I want like
kind of to stay focused on something or
what yeah to get it clear clear mind
okay just slow down it kind of
definitely helps I was like a
kinesthetic meditation kinesthetic
meditation yeah and that one's doesn't
tell me or I'll do something
symbolically so I picture like the sky
as an overcast and that's how I feel in
my head like foggy and I'll just picture
it moving like symbolically as the sun
is shining in on my head that's giving
me clarity and it works so you can even
guide people through like I said if
you're saying be a conductor you can
lead them through it like okay close
your eyes
and once you imagine your conductor I
want you to move your hand slightly back
and forth
I want you imagine the clouds in your
head vanishing and now you have clarity
like whatever you're telling yourself
then you can explain to others and
they'll follow along and it may not be
the perfect fit for somebody but even if
it's 90% of the fit it gives them a
starting point and then hopefully get
more clarity in their living so they're
jumping around your brain likes to jump
around great use it within a defined
scope of like I need to make a video
this week so how do you use your brain
so then help you make that video right
if you give yourself an infinite
timeline it's never gonna happen and as
you as you continue to post and get
better
it also shows your journey which is
going to be an inspiration for other
people to get started because people
will look at what you're doing and say
oh he's he's trying I want to try to you
become the shield for
for other people that you're taking an
effort to dois from you better and
create content it'll inspire other
people to do it too
and so especially seeing how far you
come that's why I keep all my old videos
up it's the first ones suck good Disney
one and go back and watch so watch go
watch the Disney one you'll feel better
about making your motivation okay in the
morning I love it I love that that's
fill up what you said too about
inspiring yourself in the morning like
being bold about like what makes you
feel really confident to go out like
right when you wake up yeah and having a
reminder so what's yours I think I'm
gonna watch your Disney video every day
every day
Evan sucking every day inspires me just
like it hey if he can do it and ya have
that effort you know I I can do it too
yeah that's so I know to like just um
actually mine really all jokes aside
like it's gratitude I've got that's
really changed me too
it's helped with so much and just
finding anything sometimes I'll just do
an exercise where I just think anything
in front of me I'll just anything to
look at so Thank You Evan there for
being the person that you are and I can
see you have a great heart and you care
about people and entrepreneurship so
much our wait can relate to that and
then I'll just like think that the
Starbucks coffee yeah for some reason
I'll find reasons to think it puts me in
a different mindset yeah that's really
helped me is especially with new people
is being assaulted random on the street
and having those things happen you know
your mind so consciously Thanks evade
your words you're definitely danger all
the time survival mode yeah but now
what's with turn my stress response off
that's when I meet someone I would used
to ask myself is this personally gonna
hurt me
yeah cuz I just left and right but then
I realize well what if they do hurt me
you know
yeah like how can I help this person so
I changed the chemist person hurt me -
can I help that person and just coming
from a loving standpoint and that
changed my life - it's just that
compassion for other people and have you
gone back to the place where you who you
got something um I see it when I pass
because it was on Nicholasville Road it
was pretty much like on a big
intersection area from Lexington so I
see it when I pass but yeah I look at it
and it does bring I mean like I feel
honestly like from it okay I've walked
there - and it feels right but even even
you know walking there and spending
three minutes on the same spot with
gratitude
it's really good actually as a shouldn't
do that because that's recorder doesn't
own you right we save this time and say
thank you for the same thing thank you
for this streetlight and thank you for
this Sun and thank you for this
that little signpost right and so you
release the you know that block owning
you know that's great I'm gonna go do
that actually that's a good video too
yes tell your story let's say Here I am
and here's how I'm gonna overcome true
by but now I'm going to go in sit there
in gratitude spend four minutes and and
just you can speak out over here what
you're seeing whether your eyes closed
or whatever you're however you do it so
I just want people to be their best self
to feel it myself cuz I definitely know
what it's like to not and it's a I used
to think like killing myself is the only
way to get relief but now I know that I
was completely wrong and that there's a
purpose for everyone here that everybody
matters you know like I've never had
suicidal thoughts so I can't really help
somebody with suicidal
general price I've been through
if you help somebody walk
you're about to jump off a bridge by
talking to you and they'll watch your
video and don't take a step back and
reevaluate that's gonna fill you up for
life don't make it all worth it yeah go
man action let's go if you want 25
minutes of one-on-one time with me
consulting coaching be on your podcast
interview whatever it is twenty five
minutes with me I have a special
promotion right now check that link
right next to me and I'll see you soon